how do you get these performances and i
think that my first job is to be a
really good writer
to the to the actors um you know to not
describe it
in in the script so much so many times
you see so much description
of what the character's supposed to be
feeling and stuff in screenplays and
it's just a big mistake
it has to be done through dialogue and
and what they do
it's a miracle anytime any one of them
gets made you know it's a miracle
and it's a miracle every time i feel
like it's a miracle every time a scene
kind of gets done and through the birth
canal and done i mean it's never any
less of a miracle or any less difficult
i i enrolled in nyu and i went there
for literally two days what happened was
i walked into this class and the teacher
said
you know if anyone is here to write
terminator 2 just walk out
just get out of the door and i thought
well that's just not a good way to start
what if i do want to write terminator 2
what if someone sitting next to me wants
to write you know he was sort of
instantly saying
you know we write serious films here you
know terminator 2 is a pretty awesome
movie
it just should be no fear you know i
think that's
just always remember kind of being
pummeled by fear early on and feeling
like god if i could have just got rid of
that fear earlier
this this might have been a little bit
easier just
don't give a [ __ ] that's kind of the
best thing to do you know families just
endless juicy ammunition for great
stories you know they're never going to
let you down for for good drama
or or good comedy
normally i assume you're off riding by
yourself but this one was
a little bit different i think you had
some collaboration normally i'm by
myself
or when i get lonely i kind of
turn to joanne my producer and share
things with her or even dylan the editor
but
mostly by myself but this time
i turned to daniel early on and i knew
him well enough and we've kept in touch
over the years and i knew like it would
be
foolish to just take like a year and
write by myself when i'm writing
something for him
i have to sort of take him and we have
to sort of sit in the same room together
and really work
together and he probably should have
some kind of co-writing
you know credit but he you know
that's okay and so what was the germ of
it
always this we're gonna make a love
story we're gonna make a story of
this man and this woman and that's
that's how you began
yeah like you imagine a notebook right
man and a woman
romantic sister question mark gothic
romance
all those little things that you just
kind of keep noting to yourself and then
going back and watching rebecca again
and then watching vertigo again and
watching all those things again and
looking for clues and reading daphne
demonier and kind of
filling up on stuff that was in this
venue you know caroline blackwood like
finding oh
you know amazon likes to recommend this
if you like oh wow that's that's good
you know and just
more and more and more of that and um
this story was
a little bit more fully formed than i'm
i'm i'm making it out to be there was
the idea that there was a very
strong-willed man
and a woman who enters his life and what
happens
when they discover that when he's weak
he's at his best
in terms of the relationship and how
that affects their future
so the exciting part became the research
because neither one of us really knew
much of anything about
couture or fashion in the 50s so that
became this seems so couture right now
you seem like this is a natural element
for you i'll have you know that this
sweater is cashmere
could you offer any advice to someone
who is
young bright-eyed and and earnestly
trying to get right in there
the one thing i was remember thinking
initially when i was trying to make
films and
you always felt like you got nervous
that somebody else was right who was
talking to you know who maybe was in a
position of power like that their
opinion
somehow was was right or better than
yours and somehow and
he didn't could never stop to think like
no it's just different you just think
differently than i do and that's okay
you know but i'm not wrong you know you
can get filled with such fear
and it's really easy to get to just
get your heart broken and kind of sort
of beaten and
you're sort of attempting to make films
i mean you just
it's a miracle anytime any one of them
gets made you know it's a miracle
and it's a miracle every time i feel
like it's a miracle every time a scene
kind of gets done and through
the birth canal and done i mean it's
never any less of a miracle or any less
difficult
um there's just a kind of
it just should be no fear you know i
think that's
just always remember kind of being
pummeled by fear early on and feeling
like god if i could have just got rid of
that fear earlier
this this might have been a little bit
easier just
don't give a [ __ ] that's kind of the
best thing to do no you didn't go to
film school
right why
um i think of a a weird combination of
things i think that there was
i was my plan in high school that i
wouldn't go to film school but then
you know a couple years out of high
school when i wasn't instantly directing
a movie
i started to kind of panic and and
thought about going to film school and
even did go
to ny enrolled in nyu at first what
happened was i couldn't get in anywhere
so when i couldn't get in because my
grades in high school weren't very good
so i couldn't get into college
and so what it did was create this
attitude to me like i don't need film
school
anyway because you got to find some way
to justify why you know and make it feel
good to yourself
you can't get into college you know so
you just start saying well that's
[ __ ]
you know anyway but then i started
getting really nervous i needed
something and i needed help and i i
i enrolled in nyu and i went there
for literally two days what happened was
i walked into this class and
the teacher said you know if anyone is
here to write terminator 2
just walk out just get out of the door
and i thought well that's
just not a good way to start what if i
do want to write terminator 2 what if
someone sitting next to me wants to
write
you know he was sort of instantly saying
you know we write
serious films here you know terminator 2
is a pretty awesome movie
um so he said yeah so there was an
assignment
to hand there was an assignment to write
it was you write a page
uh that that that that it has no
dialogue in it right
but you got to make sure that you you
explain something about a character you
show a character trait
through action with no dialogue right
and i had read this
this this uh great script by david mamet
which was hoffa which was not made at
the time
and there was a great scene that mammoth
had written where danny devito is
driving along his character driving
along
and it shows what he's going through by
the method he uses to keep himself awake
while driving which is he lights a
cigarette and he holds it between his
hands and he lets it burn down to his
fingers to keep him
burning and burning his fingers and
keeping him awake that's just so
simple and perfect and lovely and it's
you know
mr pulitzer prize himself david mamet so
i took that page
and i handed it in and uh
and it got a c plus
and i said all right now i know i'm
right and there's a wonderful thing that
if you drop out quick enough you can get
your tuition back
if i've ever had a theme in mind i mean
usually that's just like the worst
you're kind of then you're
yeah then you know you feel yourself you
feel yourself writing
and there's nothing worse than that
feeling of kind of chasing after
a theme i mean that's always like
writing and it's worse for me you know
the best things kind of become
something and you're just happy it's
there it's just um
the better way to go in terms of getting
better writing is having two characters
that are
more opposite you know that way you get
more traction and stuff but
um ultimately if you have if things are
going well and the characters are coming
out of you
or you know they're going to guide you
how they're going to go
and i remember at a certain point
reading
um a great short story called i believe
it's called bucket of blood
john o'hara wrote a great story about
a fella starts out he's just he wakes up
in a
hospital and he's uh he comes to
and he's having this great conversation
with a doctor he's just had his appendix
removed because his appendix is burst on
this train and he doesn't know he wakes
up he doesn't know where he was
and there's just this great conversation
at the beginning of it between a doctor
and um this patient this guy and
i started um to transcribe i just wrote
it down
in the script form thinking oh maybe
i'll this would be an adaption or
something or
as i've done before too you sort of
steal something if you you got
you're bored and you've got nothing to
do you know yeah there's no better
exercise than just write somebody else's
words down
to see how they look typed out just to
get you inspired again or to get it
moving and
that's what i was doing with this john
o'hara thing and by the look of it and
the sound of it it seemed to fit with
some of these other things that i had
had lying around so this
that character started to come more and
more and
you just start finding pieces of them
and um
you hope that they start to talk to you
yeah talk
back at you in a kind of in a weird kind
of
it sounds hocus pocus but it's like a
weird kind of seance you hope that you
are not there at a certain point that
they're just doing the work for you
that's when it's at its best i i said
this before but i did i set out to write
something really
small and cheap after boogie nights i
wanted to just make a movie small and
cheap
yeah yeah i just figured the best thing
to do here with all this sort of boogie
night stuff that was happening and sort
of attention paid to me it was really
nice but i thought
i got i wanted i should do my job you
know and my job is to just make movies
so i sat down i started to write and
there was so much happening
in my life at the time and i was just
going through so much um
personal things you know that that i
just kept writing
i kept writing what was going on around
me
whether it was whether it was me or
people that i knew um
you know i sort of just ended up just
vomiting out onto the page all the stuff
that was around me so that's what it's
about
you know that's what it's about is about
me what part of this movie is about you
all of it and that's not being really
all of it i mean um
you know um we all have families
that we you know have to figure out and
deal with and try and um
explore what went wrong
is that what interests you the most the
sort of sense of the angst or the
the dysfunctionality of a life sure
yeah yeah because that's where the
interesting stuff is it's
yeah it's you know i think that you know
families are just endless juicy
ammunition for great stories you know
they're never going to let you down for
for good drama or
or good comedy did you like that though
that precision in the cutting in that
sequence that question and answer
sequence because
that felt so new to me for you and
there's a kind of a
something i don't often think of your
films a real narrative momentum in the
in that particular scene
well let them tell the truth i don't
want to i'm not going to you know i'm
not going to tell the truth by or make
my own truth by kind of
cutting it up a bunch of different ways
and that's just luck of the draw to get
a scene that they can work like that can
actually work as a suspense scene
and and and and work as this dynamic
interplay but at the same time
you're learning something about um this
person
this character so these kinds of ideas
of screenwriting all you know plot and
momentum and character and
and you know usually the worst scenes
that you have to go do in a movie are
the ones that will
will move the story forward you know you
got to stop for a second and somebody
has to kind of
say some really horrible dialogue about
you know
well the reactor you know it will blow
up if we don't have
you know whatever it is writing can
happen pretty fast sometimes if it's
going well
and then a lot and then it's just an
excuse like you can say
i'm going to write now you know when
really you're going down and locking the
door to your room to research
to just con to to read to steal time to
kind of
fill up the um the tank
on a period you know
um or something particular
um you know this film has very
particular
things that it's based on so getting to
know that
as best as i could is time well spent
probably time
better spent than than actually typing
because that actual writing can happen
very very fast if you feel comfortable
that you're kind of connected with
that period and that time and those
people i try to avoid that moment of
like sitting down and looking at a blank
piece of paper
ever you know that kind of that you have
to put
chips in something um so you never get
to that spot
and what i mean is the energy after i've
finished
shooting a film has led me um
you have this false kind of energy i've
i've had it a few times now
where you don't collapse at the end of
it you actually feel like i could do
this again
and and what it is you're stepping back
into normal life
but you're still sort of firing on all
these cylinders a couple times now i've
gotten up
gone to gone to the coffee maker sat
down and really started to write what i
felt
i would want to make next even as vague
and bizarre
or unclear as it was it was a story of a
man and a woman a relationship
of this of that this somehow the
dialogue
starts coming okay now days later you
are
you the the energy that you've been
spending making a film and the physical
reality of what you've been through
you just sort of collapse but it's
really it's happened to me a couple
times now where i've gotten a lot of
kind of
residual energy absolutely so this like
foothold
into something that was obviously
nagging at me or all this
and it happened on this one i think
after inherent vice um
i started to sort of write a bunch of
things down straight away
that had occurred to me and that
during the course of editing that film
i was daydreaming about what this movie
would be and trying to
write things down but not trying to
write too much
and i think it was back to this thing
that we talked about before it was
wanting to not
get to a mess that i have been in before
which is writing 600 pages
yeah and having to bring it down so i
had enough ideas on this
where i felt like daydream and daydream
and think about it and turn it over in
your mind and write a little bit here
and there but never get to that spot
where you've overwritten it
or you're you haven't figured a few
things out before you really jump in
it's funny because someone's saying you
know
how do you get these performances and i
think that my first job is to be a
really good writer
to the to the actors um you know to not
describe it
in in the script so much so many times
you see so much description
of what the character's supposed to be
feeling and stuff in screenplays and
it's just a big mistake
it has to be done through dialogue and
and what they do
what are they going to are they going to
walk across the street you know then
that is that that's a character trait
you know they're making that decision
and so the scripts that i write for them
are very clean they're sort of very
clean
of a lot of sort of flowery explanation
of what they're supposed to be feeling i
think the actors really appreciate that
it lets them do their job and enable
them to just act you know what i mean
the distance between making that when i
was 17 which was this little script that
i wrote out it's like probably you know
14 or 15 pages and
writing the script for that was boogie
nights i i was constantly writing for
nine years i wrote like a full version
that was a fictional documentary like
you know like zelig it was like 80 pages
or something that
expanded it out and then i wrote another
draft you know that was the same thing
but then i decided well no i should try
to turn this into a film you know and
i tried and i wrote it as um very
probably
kind of close to what bookie knight says
now it was on there was
an exercise to learn how to write it was
almost like um
i wrote a novel like well i suppose the
first novel was more like um
like i wrote some story out that i
thought was true that really had
happened
it was like a documentary and then set
about adapting it
but when i look back on it now you talk
about how did you practice or
well like i guess i just practiced for
about eight years writing that one story
trying to
learn how to write learn how to feel
good about putting words together and
scenes together and getting it to
getting
shaping it so that it felt good that i
was confident and i wasn't embarrassed
by looking at it on the page i mean that
was really
isn't that so much of what writing is
that you're not humiliated
looking at it
you